this is a couple things i got
one um lines that were very good
trump we can't lock ourselves up in a
basement like joe has
okay we can't lock ourselves up uh in
the basement like joe has okay that was
the moment he said that that's hilarious
he's been using it it's not my fault
that the virus came here it's also not
biden's
sounds phenomenal because we've not seen
one
moment of grace no question about it
we've not seen one moment where it's
been kind of like humility
humility i i loved seeing it i thought
it was great that he said that
and it it probably brought some set
where people said well maybe he's got
that kind of asylum that we don't know
about
then there was another one that said
they paid you a lot of money and they
probably still are
trump said that i guarantee you if i
spend a million dollars on you i would
find out a ton
on you if i spend a million on you look
how much they spent 35 million dollars
on me and they found nothing on me with
russia
if i spend a million i'll find out i
think that's a very powerful one
the other one is when biden said
he thinks he's running against another
guy this is joe biden i'm here because i
beat all those other guys
i love that line the fact that he said
that i think that's a very powerful
me for biting you confuse me with bernie
meaning that's what he said
that was his i think that was nominal
yeah
exactly it wasn't canned i i agree with
you
and then the one with me on trump that
got me
like you know how you feel statement and
feeling when joe said that i felt it
i'm gonna tell you which one it was
i want to say let me explain to you why
i started a business
because of the guy yep yeah you say two
words to me i said
i'm gonna start a business and i'm gonna
whoop your
ass just because of your words when he
said i ran because of
you oh my gosh
i ran because of you joe because of what
you did i had a great life
but i ran because of you are you kidding
me that's a way that's
that's a lot of weight behind that
statement and then he says uh uh then
when they brought i think this one's
going to get him in trouble when biden
says
you know it's also the laptop is another
rush and then
trump says wait a minute the laptop's
another russia really this is a new one
the laptop's another russian
he's gonna run with that one and then
the whole thing with why couldn't you
get it done if you had all these years
but but but the conversation
trump got what he wanted to get out of
it trump said here's the one thing that
biden can't hold him
can't control himself with biden doesn't
have to answer three things
he answered it he should have never
answered it it was over moved on
okay like when he says tell me what
you're gonna do with oil but tell me
what you're gonna do with oil you're
gonna do this this is a big thing
by the way just so everybody knows texas
pennsylvania pay very close until
i hope you got what he said here's what
he's gonna do because he needs texas
he needs pennsylvania that was a big
point that he had there and you know
trump's going to know how to
uh run with that i i think to me
trump um trump schooled him if you ask
me i mean obviously the score isn't like
a
shellacking it's a 28-14 score that i
got he beat him by two touchdowns
but i think trump did exactly you know
when you're
you're debating somebody like there
wasn't a moment where biden pulled him
in
and then he he got him to say what he
wanted him to say i don't know if that
makes sense
he pulled bite never did that but he
pulled them in and
pence did it as well in his debate if
you remember that pence did the same
thing as well
so are you going to pack the courts also
is it fair to say he still has a are you
going to pack the course
oh let me talk about core packing the
court how about we talk about that out
of all the judges that you have not one
of them is african-american which is not
true
but pence needed that and he got it i
don't think
uh uh biden didn't play any flea
flickers i think trump did and he got
him
28-14 trump wins this one so